[Música]
revista de prensa en directo a América
de Francia 24 me acompaña como todas
nuestras mañanas Rosa Pérez maceu Rosa
bienvenida buena mañana de jueves y
vamos a dedicar toda esta revista de
prensa hacer un repaso por los medios
dentro de Francia No porque hoy se
preparan y ya están saliendo las calles
Casi más de un millón de personas que se
esperan para protestar contra esta
reforma al sistema pensional propuesta
impulsada por el presidente Manuel
macron y su primera ministra Elizabeth
bone empezamos con la portada en papel
del periódico lemont Buenos días Raúl
exactamente que titula macron y el test
no la prueba de la movilización Y es que
como bien decías está propuesta de
reforma del sistema de pensiones ha sido
precisamente impulsada por el gobierno
de Elizabeth Von oficialmente sin
embargo es un proyecto es social no de
sociedad de el presidente Emmanuel
macron precisamente señala que macron el
presidente no está en territorio francés
hoy precisamente está reunida reunido
con el presidente del gobierno de España
ni tampoco se le espera en la primera
línea política en los próximos días Es
una forma también de bueno de una imagen
política que acostumbra a dar macrón
también un cierto digamos una cierta
distancia Respecto a los movimientos en
las calles y por otro lado señala lumont
que los sindicatos y la nupper
recordemos la coalición de izquierdas
esperan como bien decías una gran
movilización equiparable a la de 2010
cuando se protestaba porque la edad de
jubilación en ese momento pasaba de los
60 a los 62 años Bueno y qué más
encontramos en Lemon Rosa bien una un
chat digamos en directo donde el
historiador y sociólogo Estefan Ciro
responde a las preguntas de los lectores
de este periódico y una de las críticas
que hace es a estas movilizaciones que
duran solamente un día dicen que
finalmente sirven poco para conseguir
cambios profundos no dice el ritual de
jornadas de acción de 24 horas
en el tiempo y sin que conduzcan a una
huelga indefinida y que no ponen al
poder entre las cuerdas es un modelo que
lleva al fracaso del movimiento porque
el gobierno responde con la lógica de ya
pasará y al final a pesar de las
movilizaciones nuestra propuesta es la
buena y Para cerrar con este medio
estamos por supuesto en Lemon vamos a
ver un texto de opinión firmado por el
economista Nicolás postell en contra de
esta reforma efectivamente Y es que la
mayoría de textos que encontramos en la
prensa francesa son en contra de esta
reforma del sistema de pensiones en este
caso este texto se titula viven más
tiempo trabajen más y este digamos se
sintetiza este texto con el siguiente
párrafo al optar por alargar la duración
del período de cotización el gobierno va
contra corriente de los cambios
ideológicos y económicos y
deliberadamente elige la estrategia del
conflicto social Rosa Vamos a continuar
con un texto de opinión cambiamos ahora
ya de medio de comunicación vamos Mejor
dicho con la editorial del periódico
Liberación titulado reforma de las
pensiones franceses enfadados sindicatos
despreciados y un gobierno que tiene que
preocuparse exactamente Y es que según
una sondeo del instituto el ave para bf
tv el 66% de los franceses Están en
contra de esta reforma del sistema de
pensiones y la califican en general de
injusta además critican a macron el
hecho de que impulsa un gran cambio sin
tener grandes mayorías y también digamos
sindicatos e izquierda en general se
sienten marginados sobre todo después de
las promesas del presidente de
Establecer un mayor diálogo social tras
el movimiento de los chalecos amarillos
o durante su campaña para las elecciones
presidenciales de este 2022 en que
tendió la mano sobre todo a la izquierda
para que le votaran en la segunda vuelta
contra Marín le pen y finalmente está
optando por dialogar para llegar a
acuerdos con la derecha conservadora con
los republicanos para adelante su plan
ejecutivo seguimos en Liberación Rosa
también encontramos un texto firmado por
Tomás alegrand que critica como la
fuerza pública de Francia actúa en las
manifestaciones actúa como llamo lo has
visto lo hemos visto antes con mucha
fuerza Exactamente no y es que como
señala este texto cada vez que hay
grandes movilizaciones en Francia vemos
imágenes de una fuerte represión
policial que ha sido criticada por
amnistía internacional o por Naciones
Unidas en los últimos años no
precisamente Durante este mandato de
Manuel macron o durante la mandato de
también françois precisamente dice este
texto Francia se ha convertido en un
contra modelo del mantenimiento del
orden y es que lo que ha hecho en los
últimos años es aplicar ya las tácticas
de violencia y las armas no letales que
utilizaba en las valía de las periferias
a francesas también una actuación
policial muy criticada aplicarla al
control de masas en las manifestaciones
Rosa vamos ahora con media Park este
señala la dificultad que podría tener
este movimiento contra la reforma y que
digamos aguante Más allá del día de hoy
Exactamente no Esta es un poco la línea
Que señalan varios medios de esa pues la
incógnita sobre el futuro de este
movimiento si finalmente van a conseguir
bloquear esta reforma pero nos hemos
querido fijar en un testimonio en este
reportaje que es señala una cuestión a
veces obviada por los grandes medios de
comunicación y es que hay muchos
trabajos que digamos reducen la
esperanza de vida de las personas en
este caso es el testimonio del
coordinador Nacional de la cgt de total
energys recordemos una gran
multinacional energética petrolera
refinería que dice entre los
trabajadores de Total no hay muchos que
vivan Más allá de los 75 años para
nosotros esta reforma significa dos años
menos de jubilación mientras que ya
ahora pasamos poco tiempo retirados
vamos ahora a ver qué dice la periodista
Helen sal y ella apunta que La amenaza
no no solamente es el sistema pensional
sino también contra la democracia
francesa exactamente y de hecho este
aislamiento no esta falta de
comunicación entre macron el digamos los
sindicatos y los sectores de izquierda
él en San Luis señala que puede ser
peligrosa porque puede acabar dando la
victoria a la extrema derecha en una
futuro no tan lejano Y es que dice si el
gobierno continúa ignorando las demandas
en las calles y promueve no la
consternación la resignación finalmente
social al final el descontento se
expresará de otras formas como en las
urnas Y probablemente del lado de la
extrema derecha Rosa como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de revista de prensa mañana
nos vemos o con más aquí en nuestro
programa Muchas gracias Raúl y nosotros
pasa